there was uh one of the uh the uh
inevitable first which is uh there's a
publicly listed company called
microstrategy
um a gentleman uh mr sailor decides that
uh he's gonna take it looks like about
20 of his balance sheet
uh and he's gonna move it from cash or
us dollars
into bitcoin uh but he's not doing it as
uh what i think many would refer to as
kind of a speculative
uninformed um you know gamble
right he basically clearly articulates
concerns with the macro economy
with uh inflation uh with the idea that
that cash is likely to
drastically be devalued uh in the coming
months and years
and so he is using this as a hedge
and literally at one point says i'm
going to use bitcoin as a reserve asset
uh and so it's it's kind of a currency
uh play more than it is like a
speculative i think you know bitcoin's
going to
drastically increase in value in the
future or anything like that what's your
general take on
uh kind of seeing this news yeah i mean
you know plan b
kind of this has become kind of the
nostradamus of crypto lately uh or
the person we want to be the nostradamus
of crypto i'll say uh
because we all want his his model to to
come true
actually predicted that at some point
bitcoin will become
an asset class beyond just digital gold
where it is actually used for these
purposes and it's it's fascinating to
see that
uh granted a small cap company but i i
would i would suspect it would start
with a small cap company and not start
with with apple treasury
uh would would embrace uh cryptocurrency
as as an inflation hedge whether it's
currency inflation or price inflation or
both
and clearly now now first of all this is
let's let's be clear this is a small cap
company um
he mentioned this in past i would say
almost in passing
uh in a quarterly report maybe two or
three weeks ago
realized he was getting a [ __ ] ton of
press by doing this and is now taking
advantage of that press i'm not saying
that that's a good thing or bad thing he
just is that's what that's what they're
doing
um but be that as it may they're still
doing it
and i think that sends a an incredible
message
because if you've got the cash it's way
easier
to just sit on the cash uh make two
percent
uh one and a half percent whatever it is
if you've got a good treasury and
and call it a day right nobody's gonna
get fired for doing that
no one right you now you can get fired
for basically putting money in in
bitcoin on one of those 40 days
where you put it in and it happens to to
go down
i i you know now if you've got a
long-term perspective and and you don't
care
right now the last 11 years of history
as a guide
say okay you've got a more than
reasonable chance
that in dollar terms what you're
investing is going to be worth more
than than what you put in so anyway
we'll see where this goes but it was
almost inevitable it's just fascinating
to see how
the first um the first really
interesting opportunity here
with the treasury embracing bitcoin
happened to come about
uh he's definitely milking it i have no
problem with that uh
but um you know i think what's going to
be more interesting to see
does anyone else follow suit does a
company
in like you know the the fortune
1000 embrace a certain amount of crypto
has it already happened and we don't
know about it they don't have to i don't
think they have to disclose
uh to investors how they manage treasury
uh unless it's a meaningful
you know percentage of their other book
so so i think what happens
next is is even more important but this
is fascinating
and my twitter crypto twitter has
exploded in the last few hours everybody
talking about this and so
um you know like i said what comes next
that's what i want to see
yeah part of to me that is so
interesting is
uh this isn't like a random company
on this like obscure exchange in some
foreign country
this is a an american company that's got
a market capital over a billion dollars
it's not like they took one percent
right you know it looks like 20
250 million dollars bought them about 22
000 bitcoin give or take uh and
it's trade on the nasdaq like it i think
that you know when people first start
thinking about this it's kind of like
governments like the nefarious
governments always do the the weird
stuff first and then it becomes
mainstream
right uh not saying that there's
companies that are necessarily nefarious
but just the ones that are on the fringe
usually do some of this stuff first
right
this is a nasdaq traded business that's
a billion dollar plus market cap and
the move was with hundreds of millions
of dollars
i think that that ends up being uh just
as important
as it actually happening right it's kind
of like who does it
and when does it happen right and at the
start of kind of these bull markets
seeing something like this
you start looking around the room and
you say hey you know what company
what size or what type of company uh if
they pursue this and they go ahead and
do it
is the like paul tudor jones moment
where now also the career risk is
removed
because oh apple did it or
you know maybe there's not to be that
big of a company maybe it can be a 10
billion dollar company or you know what
whatever it is there's some level where
the tipping point happens people say
i no longer have career risk to do this
because so and so did it
i just don't know where that that kind
of barometer is sure but but we've had
these
in the mid 90s we were having
discussions about the internet where we
would have conversations
well nobody gets fired for you know
integrating with
some conglomerates edi system for supply
chain management
right and most of your audience doesn't
even know what the hell they just said
so so my point is is that there was a
transition to the internet where
it wasn't necessarily a safe bet because
the internet was porn and gambling uh
from 93 to 96 and in most people's minds
and then all of a sudden it exploded and
it was mainstream and why the hell don't
you have an internet strategy
and and i think the time is coming where
finance departments are going to need to
have
a crypto bitcoin maybe defy strategy i'm
a little skeptical but we'll
we'll see what happens you know and and
so some
some variation on that with its own
terminology that's going to unfold over
the next 10 years
is going to change corporate finance
right you know treasurers and and others
within the company are going to
are going to look at you know
collateralized lending
in crypto for for for corporate growth
and it's a topic that didn't exist
in traditional finance five years ago
right so so the whole lexicon
uh the the strategies that enables it's
all going to change
and this is this is just a very you know
obviously buying and holding a small
relative even if it's 20 of your cash in
the grand scheme of things
in the united states it's a relatively
small amount of money but it still sends
a message
right the same way that the first
company moved their supply chain onto
the internet in 1997
sent a message